martin biron alec castonguay luc
ferrandez bonsoir bonsoir on a vu on a
vu le vote de grève qui a été donné à un
des syndicats qui représentent les
éducatrices y en a un est attendu demain
de la csn le plus gros syndicat on va
entendre la ministre qui répondait
entendu madame grenon on va entendre
madame grenon et on va entendre la
ministre répond dans des revues et on
veut bien mais il ya des limites puis on
en parle après
si on peut avoir un calendrier intensifs
et vendredi samedi dimanche lundi mais
on va le prendre on veut négocier règle
si j'utilise les mêmes termes que madame
lebel le tango se danse à deux enfin
comme on nous le plancher dans ces prêts
on veut danser à tous les jours donc si
on peut négocier jour et nuit on veut le
faire pour régler enfin cette négo puis
éviter les problématiques pour les
parents
ça avance plus ça avance paul de votre
perception à vous mais le présentement
j'avoue que c'est très difficile sur
l'enjeu qui a été clair depuis le début
par le gouvernement qu'on ne pourra pas
être en mesure d'offrir le même là même
la même et auteur la même capacité
d'augmentation pour tous les secteurs du
cpe
parce que pour les éducatrices le
gouvernement au premier échelon martin a
proposé 21 devra passer de 19 à 21 et de
25 à 29 pour l'échelon supérieur mais ça
comprend pas les autres travailleurs des
cpe alors rapport de force qui
s'installe puis elles ont pas mal de
pouvoir martine là où et ses bas ses
négociations qui est un peu plus
compliqué mais il ya il ya
définitivement eu madame dur dont on
disait ça prend deux pour danser le
tango si vous danser tous les jours on
va danser tous les jours ils dansent je
vous dirais ils doivent être un peu
fatigués de danser parce qu'il danse
beaucoup mais il ya des dates de
négociation qui sont en place et au
gouvernement on s'attendait à voir un
vote de grève ou si fort et on s'attend
aussi à un vote de grève demain alors il
ya une grosse stratégie qui se joue là
dessus pour les éducatrices juste pour
mettre parce que beaucoup beaucoup de
petits détails comme les employés par
exemple de candide de soutien là il y en
a plusieurs et il y en a que c'est des
petits minimes qui ont une portion
minime de travail alors c'est compliqué
d'établir tout ça mais pour comprendre
clairement pour les éducatrices l'offre
de départ du gouvernement était de 12 %
comme augmentation la demande était de
27% le gouvernement se positionne à 20%
pour ce qui est des employés de soutien
on est dans un vol dans un
une broche une fourchette assez large
mais ça c'est ça ça négocie c'est ça que
je veux dire c'est que le dossier avance
mais c'est sûr qu'il ya un rapport de
force qui s'installe et qui a le plus
gros bout du bâton alec et luc les
éducatrices où le gouvernement et les
parents sont pris entre les deux relais
les parents sont pris entre les deux si
le rapport de force s'est valu à
l'opinion publique je voudrais qu au
début de cette négociation là il était
résolument du côté des éducatrices en
garderie des syndicats et plus le temps
passe plus le rapport de force je pense
déplace du côté du gouvernement parce
que oui il faut être deux pour danser on
attend du mal à me dire oh non il faut
être deux pour danser le tango ce que
les gens voient ce que les citoyens
perçoivent c'était juste le gouvernement
qui danse depuis le début du que le
gouvernement qui améliore son offre on
est passé de 12 martin 10 à 20 % dans le
cas des éducatrices à temps plein 40
heures ont les mêmes 23 % d'augmentation
sur trois ans pour les employés de
soutien et 1 9% d'augmentation sur trois
ans et plus que les 6 pour ça que le
reste de la fonction publique a obtenu
alors les gens se disent moi je suis
d'accord que les éducatrices doivent
être mieux payés il faut valoriser leur
profession c'est important on voulait
qu'elle obtienne plus rendu à 23 % sur
trois ans il ya beaucoup de travailleurs
qui obtient autant d'argent en si peu de
temps donc là c'est clair que les grèves
commencent à peser sur les parents qui
se demandent s'il avoue continuer encore
longtemps parce que bien sûr je l'ait
peut-être pas spécifié assez clairement
il y a le spectre de grève illimitée
plus on s'approche de noël d'amande
syndicale joue avec ça pour forcer le
jeu mais l'udc ce n'est pas impensable
que ça arrive non plus non c'est pas
responsables parce que le syndicat pense
avoir deux quarts-temps son jus
premièrement le fédéral a donné six
milliards de dollars de plus à québec
pour gérer le réseau des garderies en
compensation du programme fédéral qui va
s'appliquer partout premièrement et
deuxièmement le gouvernement veut ouvrir
30 cette nouvelle belle place dans le
réseau alors le syndicat se dit si on va
avoir une capacité d'attraction pour
ouvrir des nouvelles classes dans le
réseau on a en illégitimité surtout on
est légitime surtout de dans un contexte
de pénurie de main d'oeuvre dad mandé le
maximum ouais et c'est ce qu'elle
demande on verra demain la csn va
arriver qu'un vote de grève ou si fort
l'envers
martin ça va ça va se régler peut-être
au bureau du premier ministre dans deux
semaines by abandonné le dernier tour de
roue va se donner mais chez sonia lebel
on a quand même bon espoir de régler on
se rend compte que c'est quand même
complexe bon à voir on revient sur
l'histoire des sièges celle dés
aujourd'hui madame et cannes point de
presse qui voulait répondre parce
qu'elle était responsable rappelle à
l'époque à la verrie 4 est la
protectrice du citoyen qui faisait hier
ya pas eu de plan du tout on n'a pas
regardé du côté des sièges celle des on
va écouter madame et kahn qui plaide que
il ya eu des des envois de signaux dès
le mois de janvier huit stèles
c'est une lettre qui parle des
établissements au sens large la hypo
mention non plus des hôpitaux dans cette
lettre là on ne mentionne pas des idées
des volets d'établissement spécifié
c'est un plat globale mais on dit vous
devez préparer l'ensemble de vos
établissements à faire face à une menace
qui s'appelle un nouveau coronavirus
donc ça fait appel à l'ensemble des
établissements évidemment on a commencé
à travailler tout de suite en février
bon martin qu est-ce qu on apprend
quelque chose là aujourd'hui
oui non c'est à dire de toute façon je
pense le rapport de la protectrice du
citoyen parle de lui-même c'est-à-dire
que les 6h et cd ont été laissés à eux
mêmes l'enjeu c'est maintenant qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé dans les chu cd et c'est
un peu la situation dans laquelle se
trouve le gouvernement
après tout le monde le sait là que ça a
été compliqué puis que le gouvernement
avait mal placé cb c'était beaucoup trop
avec trop insister sur les hôpitaux
maintenant il ya trois rapports
distincts l'un d'eux en cours un final
déposé il reste le rapport de la coroner
géante kamel puis le rapport de la
commissaire à la santé
hier gun france il ya un échange
l'assemblée nationale qui dit tout qui
disait tout le ministre de la santé
christian dubé répondait à une question
il dit on peut pas refaire l'histoire et
la députée du parti québécois lorraine
richard a dit je comprends qu'on peut
pas refaire l'histoire m'ont vu la
connaître l'histoire et c'est là où on
en est aujourd'hui et le gouvernement se
retrouve sur la défensive tous les jours
il va devoir bricoler quelque chose pour
qu'on sache l'histoire alec et le garder
vos idées parce que je veux faire
entendre martin en parle l'opposition
évidemment n'allait pas se priver que de
réattaquer le gouvernement là dessus
aujourd'hui une école
la protectrice du citoyen nous a dit
des signes avant-coureurs étaient là le
gouvernement savait qu'il y avait des
risques pour nos personnes dans les ch a
cédé et que aucun geste n'a été posée
qui croire il ya un enjeu ici de
confiance de la population et des
québécois il ya un enjeu d intégrité est
ce que le premier ministre est toujours
prêt à se donner une note parfaite sur
la gestion de la pandémie ou va-t-il
demander une révision note c'est une
crise innommable dans l'histoire du
québec
nous avons une dette envers les familles
des gens disparus la manière de
rembourser cette dette c'est de faire
toute la lumière je sais que le premier
ministre est isolé il a le dos au mur
ils contre attaquent pourquoi
refuse-t-il une commission d' enquête
publique lui demande qui me donne un
exemple de pouvoir qui manquent à man
castonguay
yadir éponge locke qui qui qui qui sont
pas des réponses y auriez a proposé y
auriez conquête et
on le voit à l'est qu'il est excédé
d'écouté il ya trois commissions dans
lequel il ya trois enquêtes distinctes
ça suffit changerai pas d'avis lé
basket un pur un excès que les partis
d'opposition réclament une commission
denquête public en s'appuyant sur des
données des faits des témoignages qui
vient de
d'institutions qui sont en train de
faire enquête que ce soit j'ai entamé le
coroner qu'elle soit la protectrice du
citoyen madame marie affret voiliers
vont y voir éventuellement malamute
aston villa comme sarah la santé on
n'est pas dans une situation le type
écoulée médias révèlent des informations
là à droite et à gauche sur un système
qui serait totalement étonnant que
personne n'aurait jamais vu je pense par
exemple des scandales de corruption de
collusion dans l'industrie de la
construction ou encore la nomination des
juges au niveau de la commission
bastarache couleurs on parle de loin
puis faut décortiquer décortiquer le
système faut comprendre ce qui s'est
produit pour être capable d'améliorer
parce que y'a pas d'institution en train
de faire enquête le ceppol quo ce qui
nous vient à nos oreilles du travail
très bien fait notamment de la part de
la protectrice du citoyen si ce qui
alimente la période des questions parce
qu'ils exploitent puis rené que les
partis d'opposition des environs comme
ça en est alors que dans le fond
deux réponses à nos questions déjà
est-ce qu'on aurait davantage de réponse
avec une commission d' enquête publique
peut-être à la marge mais pour l'instant
je trouve que le rapport la protection
du citoyen honnêtement en 72 pages de
précision de concision ont vraiment
amener beaucoup beaucoup de d'éclairage
sur plusieurs aspects de la crise mais
elle et elle ne fait pas la même analyse
que le premier ministre allait clé la
protectrice du citoyen elle est beaucoup
plus dure est dit on a on les a laissés
tomber l'on a transféré des gens là
n'étaient pas équipés luc
bon monsieur legault est arrivé avec un
système de ch et celtique était prêt
existant avec tous les défauts qu'il a
il a fait preuve d sous science dans les
deux premières années de son mandat mais
le système des ch et celles dites
étaient là étaient dépourvues de
suffisamment de personnel de
suffisamment d'expertisé 10 de
gestionnaires de direction à la tête de
chaque 6 h et celle des deux capacités
d'apprentissage aux employés c'était là
alors je vois pas pourquoi il ne fait
pas simplement l'avouer en disant mais
écoutez oui c'est vrai et un système à
réformer on a fait des premières
réformes on a nommé des gestionnaires à
la tête on a mis on a formé dix mille
employés et on travaille sur par exemple
le nouvel apport de main d'oeuvre qui
doit être apportée par déjà les agences
comment l'encadrer pourquoi il est allé
s'embourber dans un refus de l'évidence
et madame mais cannes encore pire en
prétendant qu'il y avait une lettre qui
circule et c'est pas une lettre qui
circule qui permet de faire une
stratégie face à une pandémie
ce sont des réunions quotidiennes ce
sont des argumentaires techniques ce
sont des outils techniques pourquoi
est-ce qu'ils s'obstinent ils c'est un
type du bonbon pour l'opposition martine
parce que l'opposition ne lâchera pas
s'il n'y a pas d'élément nouveau vous
allez me dire qu'un autre sujet qui va
arriver mais quand même non mais c'est
vrai parce que l opposition à papa de
ses réponses on sait que et cesser de
blâmer le gouvernement parce que quand
même
man communiqué lundi le gouvernement
était pris avec le réseau très haché cd
qu'ils avaient à partir du moment où il
s'est rendu compte que c'était
l'hécatombe dans les réseaux de ces ssd
c'est vrai que monsieur legault a fait
des efforts c'est documenté j'en ai
jusque là tu allais qu'a écrit là-dessus
on sait que eu des efforts pour essayer
de régler la situation mais qu'est ce
qui s'est passé à l'intérieur des ch et
celle des j'écoutais le reportage de
du collègue gêne-t-il et et c'est un peu
ce que les gens veulent savoir comment
ça s'est passé commun à la pierre ça
c'est réglé et tant que ces réponses
deviennent verts ne vont pas répondre d'
alice et son
rapport
les recommandations du rapport d'un
corner les recommandations du rapport de
la commissaire la santé vont être
importants parce que là la protectrice
du citoyen ne recommande pas la tenue
d'une enquête publique alors messieurs
ont pu se réfugier là ils l'ont peu
d'hier mais je pensais qu'il dirait plus
mais l'api je lui ai posé la question à
la protection et l a dit si le ministre
il donc le gouvernement s'engage à
chaque six mois nous faire une reddition
de comptes où on est rendu dans les
recommandations d'ouvrir les lie à 10
mois joie est correcte avec salles de
classe
mais absolument moi je pense que la
seule raison pour laquelle on veut
qu'une enquête publique c'est pour
étirer le dossier jusqu'à le rouge qu'au
début d'année électorale c c'est de
bonne guerre de la part de l'opposition
c'est une stratégie évidente et pourquoi
monsieur legault est très laid leur
prêter flanc pourquoi il a accepté de
ceux de s'inscrire dans une espèce de
négation qui est qui était possible
d'ailleurs parce que c'est tellement
bien documentée par la coroner par la
protectrice du citoyen c'est tellement
bien documenté et c'est ça fait
tellement de sens que de dire non il y
en avait pas de problème moi on a agi au
mieux nos connaissances il avait juste à
dire c'est un agi au mieux nos
connaissances m'ont été pris avec un
système qui je vois pas pourquoi il a
posé cela allait qu'on a
aussi dans la psychologie de quelqu'un
qui a été au centre de cette crise là
depuis le début c'est comme si il avait
s'il disait par exemple ça a été
épouvantable on a mal géré le début de
cette crise donne un sachet se lier aux
nomades je sais ça c'est comme si il
trouve ça injuste de dire ça compte tenu
des efforts qui ont été faits quand ils
ont vu l'ampleur de la crise et compte
tenu de ce qu'il savait à l'époque parce
qu'elles vont rappelons nous aussi on en
est et où au mois de mars dernier on
était dans une situation assez
différente où on a voulu protéger les
hôpitaux parce que c'est ce qu'on voyait
en europe ce qu'on voit en italie c'est
ce qu'on voyait à new york les hôpitaux
débordés on a fait a posteriori une
erreur c'est à dire qu'on n'en négliger
un système de réseau de sièges celle des
très faibles on a mal calculé notre coup
on les a oubliés on les a mal préparé il
n'avait pas l'expertisé n'est pas la
main d'oeuvre y avait pas les
équipements de protection bref tout ce
qui était documenté vraie celle du
palais est ce que vous dites là il dit
pas comme ça monsieur leubou baïdy easy
qui dit on va faire notre possible avec
ce qu'on servait il différemment de moi
légaux mais
non n'y a pas d'élection qu'en fait
c'est que vous aller un peu plus loin au
québec parce que je pense qu'il veut pas
monter mais pas des prix on on a
vraiment complètement fait le contraire
de ce qu'on pense et ils ont fait du
mieux qu'il pouvait au moment où ça se
produise des psaumes et il veut pas en
démordre ils le pensent mais la plupart
des gens font le mieux qui pense tout le
temps mais s'imposer comme trop
d'erreurs c'est vrai vous 3 rapidement
la gouverneure générale
le sénateur carignan 10 a pas de bon
sens dans le passé bien français sert on
devrait
passer une loi pour obliger la
gouverneure générale ou pays à être
quand même très bien où j'en lettres
là-dessus tour de table khaleq martin
lück
en tant qu'institution elle doit être
bilingue est parfaitement bilingue en
tant que personne on comprend qu'elle ne
le soit pas alors il faut que comme
personne elles rejoignent les
institutions il faut que la fin de son
mandat elles le deviennent alors
monsieur carignan raison de dire ça
aucun bon sens que la gouverneure
générale ne représente pas bien comme il
faut dans sa langue huit millions de
personnes à travers le canada mais donne
en lui une chance pour qu'elle puisse
rejoindre ce statut là qu'on a qu'on
attend du gouverneur général
avec
comprendre le symbole qu'on a voulu
qu'on a voulu appliquer du côté du
gouvernement premières venant général
autochtone les je comprends qu'on ait
donc voulu frapper un grand coup étant
donné tout le le contexte actuel des
pensionnats autochtones la
réconciliation mais je pense qu'on a
créé un précédent là qui devra être
colmatée je pense que pour s'assurer que
la prochaine ou le prochain gouverneur
général parle français carignan un peu
raison je pense que ça devrait pas
quelque chose qui se reproduit le même
pourquoi semaine dimitri soudas ce nous
a révélé hier que il y avait eu des
rumeurs mais qu'elle était sur la courte
liste pour être nommé en 2010 et que
monsieur harper lui a dit je suis
deuxième speak french on peut pas la
nommer martine c'est ça parce que et
parce que ça en fait selon son discours
hier étaient très correctes on n'avait
pas de grandes attentes la parler un peu
français c'était correct en fait ce qui
est surprenant dans le cas de marie
sabine csn domination pourquoi est ce
que le premier ministre a décidé de
nommer quelqu'un qui ne parle pas les
deux langues officielles est là dessus
moi aussi je trouve que monsieur karim
n'a pas tort quand il disait peut-être
qu'on devrait encadrer s'assurer que le
gouverneur général du canada par les
deux langues c'est ça et mais comme dit
luc
elle pu montrer que qu'elle comprend
puis le les besoins de l'instruction un
niveau personnel et devenir trilingue
parce qu'elle est déjà bilingues mais
devenir thriller merci beaucoup d'autant
plus triste qu'une en dehors de la
chambre son travail c'est de rencontrer
les gens le centre-ouest de représenter
le canada en rencontrant les gens à
travers le canada et il va falloir
qu'elles apprennent le français qu'elle
appelle bien j'en fais là je vous dis
adieu à la prochaine c'est la pause à
voir pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
oh